This is not good news and it could slow down
those really great vaccination numbers that
I just told you about.
U.S. regulators are now calling for a complete
and total pause on using the Johnson and Johnson
coronavirus vaccine because of six blood clot
cases that have happened among six million
people who have received the Johnson and Johnson
vaccine.
So the first piece is that the FDA and the
CDC have already decided they will no longer
use the vaccine at federal vaccination sites.
They are urging states to also pause.
And as far as I know, basically every state
is doing it.
I know people who were scheduled to get their
JNJ shot today.
Their appointment has been canceled.
What we know so far, per The New York Times,
is that six recipients in the US developed
a really rare disorder that involves blood
clots within about two weeks of vaccination.
It's six people, all women between the ages
of 18 and 48.
One woman died.
A second woman in Nebraska has been hospitalized
and is in critical condition nearly.
It's actually not six.
It's nearly seven million people in the U.S.
have received the JNJ shot so far.
Nine million more doses have been shipped
to states which presumably will just be held
for the time being.
Dr. Peter Marks, who directs the FDA's Center
for Biologics Evaluation and Research, put
out a statement along with the principal deputy
director of the CDC, Anne Schuchat, and they
said, quote, We are recommending a pause in
the use of the vaccine out of an abundance
of caution.
So let's talk the numbers through six incidents
out of about seven million vaccinations.
The first question is, was this caused by
the vaccine or did these six individuals have
some underlying disorder or abnormality that
was exacerbated by the vaccine?
Other questions that are being looked at include,
given that we're talking about all six of
the individuals were women age 18 to 48.
Could this be connected to some kind of medication,
for example?
And this is just an example.
There's no evidence of this, but this is the
type of question that's being asked.
If all six of these women were on oral contraceptives,
the birth control pill, that would be something
to look at.
We just don't know yet.
And while it's been while it's being investigated,
it's going to be a setback in the vaccination
program.
Everybody is being clear right now that there
is not a causal relationship here, but it
has to be investigated.
In the U.S., somewhere between 300000 and
600000 people per year develop blood clots
generally, but not this particular kind of
blood clot.
This is a cerebral venous sinus thrombosis.
It's very, very rare.
And we have to do it safely.
That has to be priority number one.
We also have to make sure that this is reported
on in a responsible way.
You know what's going to be on Fox News tonight?
The anti vaccines are already saying, see,
we were right about all of it.
Well, no, you the same people said MRSA vaccines
are really, really dangerous.
And it actually it's been the two adenovirus
vaccines that we are seeing, this blood clot
issue with the JMJ vaccine here in the U.S.,
AstraZeneca, in Europe and in other places.
Remember that out of 34 million people who
received the AstraZeneca vaccine in Britain,
as well as the EU and and three other countries,
there were 222 of these blood clot incidents
linked with a low platelet level.
So slightly different situation.
It's it's been the adenovirus vaccines where
we've seen this, not the marnay.
And so when the same people that we're talking
about MRSA come forward and say all of these
vaccines are unsafe, let's let's not allow
them to to get Galab us.
Let's talk now about the effect on just the
vaccination program in the United States with
the JMJ doses, we were expecting to have enough
for all 260 million adults in the U.S. by
the end of next month, by the end of May.
Didn't mean everybody would have received
their shots by then, but there would be enough
support.
Without the Johnson and Johnson doses, most
adults, there would be enough supply for two
hundred and thirty million adults.
That's not everybody, that's not all 260 million.
But so many people are refusing to get the
vaccine that in practice, even without the
JMJ doses, there very well could still be
enough doses for every adult who wants the
vaccine to get one.
And that supply would be available by the
end of May.
So we could be depending on how many people
want the vaccine.
This could be a delay of a few weeks.
And getting to where we hope to get it could
be a delay of a couple of months.
There are other countries that are so dependent
on future doses of the JMJ vaccine that if
this doesn't get resolved in a way that it's
deemed to be safe and the JMJ vaccination
continues, it could really be a disaster for
the plans of of of some other countries.
The vaccine might also come back online relatively
quickly, but with some demographic restrictions.
If we can determine that there's something
about why it's only affected six women, do
you say, well, we're bringing it back online,
but only men should get the JMJ vaccine?
This is idle speculation, but these are the
things medical regulators are going to be
looking at.
So not the news that we wanted.
We continue vaccinating with the Pfizer and
the Moderna vaccines.
Deaths are continuing down.
Cases are level.
And if we can trace the variants successfully,
cases should be significantly lower in about
a month.
And we will continue following what happens
with the JMJ vaccine, as well as other distribution
cases, variants and all of that.
Let me know your thoughts if you've received
the JMJ vaccine already, but you're within
the two week period during which these reactions
are happening, are you worried or are the
numbers so low that it doesn't concern you?
Let me know.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.